[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un amoureux de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
confinement les événements ont décidé de
sortir et de faire du sport ce week-end
ils étaient nombreux dans les parcs et
dans les structures de sport en plein
air reportage à suivre
boxe dp xbox basée à villes peuvent
organiser le samedi 3 avril un combat au
complexe sportif alain mimoun ce combat
opposera anthony karpin numéro 4
français yoann bloyer dans la catégorie
des poids lourds-légers interview dans
quelques instants
football vous l'avez peut-être vu sur
les terrains à 2 ligue 2 félicien gazon
a notamment affecté le match entre
dunkerque et new york c'est arbitres
originaire de plaisir sera avec nous
dans ce magazine pour parler de son
expérience
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
vous le savez le département des
yvelines est de nouveau confiné depuis
ce samedi pour une durée de quatre
semaines minimum la plupart des éminents
ont décidé de profiter des premiers
rayons de soleil du printemps pour
réaliser des activités en extérieur et
notamment du sport tout cela en
respectant le périmètre des 10 km
autorisée par les autorités
un montage de xam xam pour ce premier
week-end de confinement les yvelinois
ont décidé de sortir pour faire du sport
tout en respectant le rayon des 10 km
imposées par les autorités à plaisir une
partie de pétanque s'organisant le parc
d'autres n'ont pas hésité à enfourcher
leur bicyclette
voilà je faire du vélo la du vélo tout
le long du parc là et puis j'ai
peut-être m'arrêter un petit peu voilà
prendre un peu le soleil un vu qu'il est
encore là
voilà profiter un petit peu ça va faire
du bien j'ai besoin de verdure des
espaces
de me balader du sport également à
voisins le bretonneux ce dimanche matin
des enfants font du roller dans cette
aire de jeu ici à 50 mètres cette
famille joue au rugby sur l'herbe depuis
plus d'une heure sinon resteraient entre
quatre murs dans le salon on aurait un
peu en rond donc heureux à nancy très
bien de pouvoir s'aérer en plus ya pas
mal d'espacés verts autour de la maison
on en profite ici ça fait du bien ça
fait beaucoup de bien même tu es je peux
aller au collège
malgré le confinement ouais ça fait du
bien en ce qui concerne le sport encadré
en extérieur les structures ouvertes à
la pratique ont accueilli presque autant
de public que d'habitude au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
parking est plein ce dimanche plus de
250 golfeurs sont présents sur le site
un chiffre élevé pour la saison ce
week-end voilà il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de joueurs de la région des dix
kilomètres qui viennent jouer ici ça
peut permettre à des gens aux alentours
qui avait l'habitude de jouer sur
d'autres parcours de venir jouer au golf
national et de découvrir nos parcours ce
nouveau confinement devrait durer au
minimum pendant quatre semaines
on va maintenant parler volley ball dans
le championnat élite l'un des seuls
championnat encore autorisé la pratique
en compétition le club de conflans
andresy jouy s'est imposé ce week-end
sur le terrain de charenton dernier du
classement
le score est serré 3 sets à 2 25 17 22
25 25 20 19 25 et 9 à 15 grâce à cette
victoire conflent entre dans le top 3 de
la poule prochain match ce samedi à
19h30 à domicile contre cesson une
performance également en golf libinois
charlotte liothier va emporter ce
dimanche l'une de ses plus belles
victoires sur le circuit international
en gagnant les internationaux d'italie
dame a en tête après trois tours la
joueuse de saint nom la bretèche a
consolidé son avance le dernier jour en
signant une ultime carte de 71
charlotte liothier aura 22 ans en mai
prochain et elle pourrait être parmi les
meilleures joueuses du circuit dans les
prochaines années on va maintenant
parler à box vp xbox basée à villepreux
va organiser le samedi 3 avril un combat
de boxe au complexe sportif alain mimoun
ce combat opposera anthony karpin numéro
4 français à yoann bloyer dans la
catégorie des poids
pour les jets ce combat sera à huis clos
pour nous parler de ce rendez-vous alban
à bennacer est avec nous président de vp
xbox ainsi que l'ia abako coach et
boxeuses bonsoir bonsoir michael alors
ce combat était-il attendu par tous les
passionnés de boxe
alors en fait c'est une c'est une
revanche d'un combat qui avait déjà eu
lieu en 2019
donc les deux boxeurs s'étaient
rencontrés et anthony karpin avait avait
perdu malheureusement donc là ce sera ce
sera le riz match et en plus on a la
chance d'avoir le quatrième français
chez les lourds légers donc une belle
une belle affiche une belle affiche
est ce que le favori de la rencontre du
coût sera anthony karpin qui est numéro
4 français
le favori alors sur le papier peut-être
je le rappelle c'est son bilan ses douze
combats cinq victoires dont 2 par ko et
yoann bloyer est lui un boxeur un petit
peu plus expérimenté avec 60 combats
pour 19 victoires dont 3 par k o
exactement ouais c'est ce que j'allais
c'est ce que j'avais souligné il est un
peu plus expérimentés c'est un
adversaire très valeureux un gaucher à
ces techniques alors qu'anthony karpin
lui est un droitier donc ça va être un
peu une opposition de style est sur le
papier peut-être anthony karpin
légèrement favori mais on sait jamais ce
qui peut se passer en boxe donc on verra
ça le 3 avril il ya qu'est ce qui fera
la différence peut-être dans ce combat
la boxe du gaucher cc d'ambac ce qui
surprend toujours en tant que droitier
on n'est pas n'est pas toujours prêts à
affronter des gauchers donc je pense que
ça va être un combat intéressant alors
le combat va s'organiser sur six rounds
de trois minutes
est ce qui est un avantage pour un des
deux
boxer ou porc parce qu'a priori on a été
confinée pendant pendant assez longtemps
david est mesurée pendant la santé en
plus qu'il soit prêt et pour qu'ils
aient à que je pense de combattre donc
je pense que leur condition physique
sera tous les deux au rendez vous
beaucoup
alors la question que tout le monde se
pose c'est pourquoi organiser ce combat
à villepreux alban bennacer alors très
bonne question en fait alors je vais
souliers juste pour rebondir sur ce qui
a été dit on est à huit clos évidemment
compte tenu du contexte et des
protocoles sanitaires notamment de la
fédération française de boxe
pourquoi villepreux parce que c'est
aussi un moyen de mettre en lumière le
club et de pas rester un petit peu
spectateur de la situation si
particulière qu'ont traversé tous avec
les différentes restrictions donc de
remettre la boxe aussi de donner de la
visibilité à la boxe notamment
professionnelle parce qu'on sait que
c'est difficile aujourd'hui pour les
boxeurs pros de survivre les temps sont
durs et du coup voilà c'était
intéressant pour nous de montrer notre
soutien à la boxe professionnelle et de
mettre le club et la ville de villepreux
aussi en lumière puisque je signale que
villepreux et aires de jeux 2024 donc
alors sur ce sur ce combat du coup il
soit il sera à huit clos forcément est
ce qu'il n'ya pas une petite déception
quand même quand on est amateur de boxe
on va pas avoir la chance de vivre ça en
entendant les bruits
et en vivant l'atmosphère l'ambiance
mais c'est déjà bien de pouvoir avoir
pour pouvoir avoir sa part dont je pense
qu'il ya un peu de déception même temps
on est content on est on attend ce
combat plus qu'autre chose est ce que ça
joue pas justement le fait qu'il n'y ait
pas de public ça va se passer comment à
votre avis alors ça va être en fait on
aura les officiels donc on aura
j'arbitre unique délégué de réunions
chronométreur le médecin ça c'est ce
qu'on a habituellement sur tous les
combats on aura évidemment les
entraîneurs qui sont dans le coin des
boxeurs des deux boxeurs et puis ensuite
la salle est vite évident pardon à
savoir ce sera diffusé et enfin sera
retransmis sur facebook sur mtp boxing
donc voilà je les cite
mais du coup il y aura une
retransmission quand même sur sur
internet même si la salle et les gradins
seront seront vides c'est ce qu'on
appelle du pp review 1 c'est bien ça
c'est du paper view exactement on paye
pour voir le combat
c'est exactement ça d'euros 29 par par
personne on a souhaité garder un tarif
abordable aussi pour le plus grand
nombre
et puis ça permet de compenser un petit
peu l'absence de public donc c'est
intéressant de ce point de vue là aussi
c'était peut-être l'une des idées des
conditions peut-être de la préfecture de
pour organiser ce combat que ça soit
huit clos que cela soit retransmis sur
les réseaux sociaux est exactement alors
la retransmission n'est pas une
condition on peut on est libre
d'organiser et tant qu'on y est tant
qu'on est à huis clos puisque c'est du
sport professionnel
après le pp review c'était vraiment un
choix pour apporter un peu de force
aussi aux combattants et que que leur
public puisse les regarder ce jour là
vous allez tenter quand même d'avoir un
petit peu de public ou pas du tout pas
du tout on peut vraiment enfin c'est
vraiment interdit on peut on ne peut pas
se permettre
je les conditions on ne peut pas le
faire est-ce qu'il ya toujours un doute
peut-être d'organiser cet événement ou
pas du tout c'est à dire un doute sur
organisation le contexte sanitaire est
ce que vous pensez que
ce combat ira au bout oui moi je pense
que oui je pense qu'elles vont à été
puisque c'est lui attire vers cette
organisation entre autres on va dire non
je pense que on a été assez prudent par
rapport à ça et il est temps maintenant
de relancer un peu la machine ça
commence par ça ça ira plus en plus tard
jeté trois mois passés a demandé
l'aboutissement du projet alban vous
confirmez
pas d'annulations a pas d'annulations
dans les crp ont le souhaitent
on fera tout pour et voilà après rien
n'est jamais acquis dans la vie en
général et en boxe encore j'ai à dire
encore plus mais en tout cas voilà le
souhait de tout le monde sait que le
combat ait lieu après quand même ce
serait un peu prétentieux de dire que
tout repose sur moi les deux boxeurs
aussi les deux acteurs principaux
il ya une très bonne équipe au sein du
club on a la chance d'avoir l'ia ici
présentés puis sans oublier emmanuel
romain larripa ce cadet thomas j'avais
tous les sites et donc tout le monde à
participer
voilà c'est une oeuvre collective avant
tout c'est important pour l'image du
club d'organiser ce type d'événement
vous êtes un nouveau club
c'est vrai qu'on a un nouveau club lou
ce qu'on souhaite s'est professionnalisé
au maximum le club et puis le la boxe en
général donc c'est aussi en filigrane
cette envie de professionnaliser de
donner de la visibilité de montrer aux
adhérents qu'on continue de faire vivre
le club dans la période
un petit peu difficile on continue de
s'entraîner aussi en extérieur donc ça
fait partie de la vie du club et c'est
important pour nous et sk une
effervescence au club autour de ce
combat est ce que tout le monde en parle
je sais pas par exemple on a nous on au
petit paris disons entre nous un anneau
à nos pronostics mais ça reste ça reste
personnel à détroit par ci par là est ce
qu'il y aura d'autres combats où c'est
le dernier c'est un one shot ou est ce
qu'on aura d'autres qu'on va nous
souhaitons on en refera d'autres c'est
sûr on organisera probablement des
combats amateurs aussi quand les
conditions seront réunies
donc là on va dire que c'est un coup de
c'est un coup d'essai c'est une première
mais ce sera le début d'une d'une longue
série on va dire si vous avez déjà des
dates de prévues ou pas du tout pas du
tout non non pas du tout on navigue à
vue là on
ont désorganisé celui-là apprend après
on verra est exactement mais en tout cas
ce sera ce sera fait il y en aura
d'autres merci à tous les deux alors je
vous garde quand même avec nous pour une
dernière information boxe on a eu des
nouvelles d'ahmed el moussaoui le boxeur
originaire de la verrait un signe avec
le promoteur américain about balyan sa
promotion
un groupe qui s'occupe de plusieurs
sportifs et notamment deux boxeurs aux
états unis ahmed el moussaoui 30 ans
attend désormais une date pour son
prochain combat il n'a pas combattu
depuis juillet 2020 l'illinois affiche
pour l'instant un bilan de 33 victoires
pour un nul et trois défaites
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alban
bennacer vous le connaissez un je crois
oui oui j'ai eu l'occasion de le croiser
quelques quelques reprises je pense que
c'est un bon boxeur
et puis c'est une bonne opportunité pour
lui aujourd'hui la boxe professionnelle
en france souffre de beaucoup de
beaucoup de mots le statut du boxeur
professionnel mériterait d'être amélioré
donc toute opportunité pour un boxeur
professionnel prometteurs comme lui est
bon à prendre je pense il pourrait aller
boxer peut-être aux états unis sont par
l'option ça lui appartient c'est des
choix déterminants je le rappelle il est
il est encore jeune je pense qu'il est
bien entouré donc les choix
appartiennent à sa team mais en tout cas
ça peut être intéressant pour lui je
pense merci c'est sur ce plateau le
combat entre anthony kerfah et yoann
bloyer programmé ce 3 avril au gymnase
alain mimoun à villepreux le match sera
à suivre sur les réseaux sociaux voient
maintenant ouvrir une page football on
parle souvent des footballeurs mais peu
à des arbitres nous sommes allés à la
rencontre d'un jeune arbitre heavy noah
gabriel henry l'un des plus prometteurs
de sa génération sont portés par bixente
mérian santisteva c'est l'un des
arbitres les plus prometteurs de france
gabriel henry 22 ans a découvert
l'arbitrage il y à 7 ans alors qu'il
était gardien de but et éducateur au
voisin football club
on va demander
de dépanner sur un tournoi d'être
arbitre pour le club et ça m'a vachement
plus et donc c'est comme ça qu'est venue
cette idée de l'arbitré après le club à
inscrire la formation initiale et j'ai
commencé j'ai commencé le premier match
en district comme ça du district des
yvelines à la france entière
gabriel a gravi les échelons au fil des
années il est aujourd'hui arbitre
principal en nationale 2 4e division
nationale il apprend également aux côtés
des plus expérimentés moi j'observe
beaucoup les arbitres qui sont plus
expérimentés que moi ça soit au dessus
en liga ou même en même niveau que moi
j'ai la chance de faire 4e aussi
quatrième arbitre en ligue 2 et donc là
c'est le moment où j'apprends le plus
parce que je vois une approche
professionnelle de l'arbitrage et pour
moi c'est hyper enrichissant même s'il a
déjà plusieurs rencontres de haut niveau
à son actif une seule lui vient en tête
lorsqu'on lui demande son plus beau
souvenir forcément non plus beau
souvenir c'est la finale de la coupe
gambardella 2019 que j'ai la chance de
faire au centre au stade de france
donc devant un petit paquet de monde
s'était fait assez sympa entre donc
c'était toulouse contre saint-etienne ce
jour là il prépare sa rencontre du
week-end un match de ligue 2 entre le
havre et sochaux où il officiera en tant
que quatrième arbitre
quant à ses objectifs il ne s'en fixe
pas pour le moment j'ai déjà
prendre chaque match après chaque match
comme comme disent les joueurs de foot
et puis non c'est simplement c'est
surtout de prendre du plaisir parce que
l'arbitrage avant tout c'est pour moi
c'est du plaisir c'est une passion j'ai
mes études de kiné à côté donc c'est
cela la priorité après l'arbitrage c'est
pour moi c'est juste que du bonheur donc
temps que je peux continuer à pratiquer
je continuerai la crise sanitaire n'a
pas changé la routine d'entraînement du
jeune arbitre
bien que le championnat de nationale 2
soit actuellement suspendu on continue à
parler arbitrage vous l'avez peut être
vu sur les terrains de ligue 2 cet
événement notamment bris arbitrer le
match entre dunkerque et niort qui s'est
soldé par une victoire 2 à 0 pour les
dunkerquois félicien gazon était rentré
sur la pelouse après la blessure de
l'arbitré central félicien à gazon
originaire de plaisir est avec nous
bonsoir merci pour l'invitation
alors on va tout d'abord parlé de ce
match à skull c'est un bon souvenir ou
pas un super souvenir c'était vraiment
plus grands matchs arbitrés pour le
moment ligue 2 le meilleur niveau que
j'ai pu arbitrer donc avoir un super
souvenir
qu'est ce que ça fait de rentrer sur un
terrain de ligue 2 c'était c'était la
première fois du coup la première fois
très stressant au depor au moment où
j'ai dû rentrer à la 35e' 37e minute
donc voilà très stressant à prévoir la
victime est dans le match et faire le
travail et essayer de mener la rencontre
à son terme donc où est très concentrée
pour la suite
alors selon certains observateurs vous
avez changé la physionomie du match
entre dunkerque et niort on voit tes la
pression autour de ces matches est ce
que c'est quelque chose que vous que
vous découvrez ou pas du tout tout à
fait alors j'ai eu des décisions fortes
à prendre donc selon certains
observateurs en effet yves un carton
rouge et un rouge un penalty où j'ai
décidé de ne pas siffler donc avoir des
décisions importantes qui ont pu changer
la physionomie du match en effet mais
wells une découverte pour moi c'est déjà
des sensations qu'on retrouve au niveau
national 2 dans lequel officie
habituellement mais mais voilà ce niveau
là avec son niveau de pression c'était
c'était tout nouveau pour moi donc une
découverte plus de pression c'est
logique finalement use it y est préparé
à ça alors ça reste un match de football
mais
mais oui au moment d'entrer en jeu
beaucoup de pression mais après par la
suite vite se concentrer et rentrer dans
le match no alors on va revenir sur sur
votre histoire vous êtes licencié ou fo
plaisir pourquoi avoir voulu devenir
arbitre je suis licencié au wef au
plaisir tout à fait depuis l'âge de 7
ans à peu près et à l'âge de 17 ans g1
dirigeants de mon club qui m'a proposé
de passer la formation initiale de
découvrir les lois du jeu au district
chose que j'ai immédiatement accepté que
qui me plaisait et j'ai accroché j'ai
tout de suite accroché c'est devenu
lui-même une passion et on m'a vite
demandé de choisir entre arbitres et est
jouée à partir de l'âge de 18 ans et
demi à peu près puisque j'avais plus
lâche d'arbitrer des jeunes donc j'ai
choisi l'arbitrage et c'est vraiment
réellement devenu une passion donc je
regrette pas du tout alors si je m'en
viens maintenant vous ne pouvez plus
jouer au football en club voit tout à
fait alors elle profite à partir d'un
certain niveau et d'un certain âge on ne
peut plus avoir la double casquette
joueurs arbitres en effet donc exact
alors du coup vous avez arbitré pour la
première fois c'était en 2014
est-ce que vous souvenez de votre
premier match oui je me rappelle c'était
à saint cyr l'école c'était mon match on
passe la formation théorique et derrière
on est on est évalué sur un match un
terrain où on est on il estime si on est
apte ou pas à continuer et on a notre
première écusson officielle donc la voie
tout à fait j'ai c'était saint cyr
l'école face au pecq est certain c'est
un super souvenir aux chaussures que
nature pour son église était du 15e
yvelinois tout à fait est-ce que vous
avez accroché tout de suite
ou est ce que vous vous êtes dit c'est
peut-être pas forcément fait pour moi
c'était vraiment porte curiosité au
depor et la fonction d'arbitré m'a tout
de suite plu et après c'est au fur et à
mesure avec les années et enfin les mois
et des années qui ont qui défilent que
là où ça devient vraiment une passion
et oui après c'est avec le temps que
c'est vraiment vraiment devenu un
plaisir et si vous a plu au départ c'est
peut-être le le contact peut être avec
les les joueurs s'est imposé ces enfants
c'est une découverte c'est quelque chose
que je connaissais pas vraiment sur le
terrain en tant que joueur
manager un une rencontre avec différents
environnements les joueurs les bancs de
touche le public jongler entre tous ces
environnements faire passer des
décisions prendre des responsabilités
aussi ça m'a fait grandir aussi en tant
que jeune en tant qu'adolescent donc
ouais l'arbitrage c'est quelque chose
qui a beaucoup changé d'un mois beaucoup
changé en tout cas dans ma vie est-ce
que comment a réagi votre entourage
forcément quand on dit je sais pas je
veux devenir arbitre certains se posent
et peut-être des questions est-ce que ça
a été le cas pour vous c'est vrai que
quand on est jeune on rêve tous d'être
zinedine zidane ou ronaldinho donc c'est
devenir arbitre c'est pas forcément la
vocation rêvait de tous même si
maintenant et beaucoup de jeunes qui
rêvent de l'être mais oui alors un peu
peut-être une surprise au depor mais
après vite très vite compris pour ma
famille est soutenue surtout donc
c'était fin c'est très agréable
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est de plus
en plus difficile de devenir arbitre
alors de devenir arbitre et revenant
cette vocation de devenir arbitre nommé
d'officier dans un certaine dans
certaines divisions où il fallait alors
surtout au niveau des portemanteaux dans
les basses divisions ça peut parfois sur
certains terrains être compliqué on
n'est pas forcément quand on commence
quand on est jeune
entouré on est parfois sans assistant
officiel son délégué donc on se retrouve
vite seul sur certaines rencontres ce
qui n'est pas forcément évident quand on
est jeune donc voilà c'est important
d'être de soutenir les jeunes orbite
rotation est ce que vous êtes bien
encadrés par les instances notamment le
district des îles je crois que vous avez
des formations régulièrement
c'est bien ça alors j'ai pu bénéficier
de ces formations du district des
yvelines au depor tu de la ligue de
paris
j'ai évolué au niveau régional pour la
suite donc quoi j'étais super bien
encadrés j'ai eu des formateurs qui
m'ont qui m'ont pris sous leurs ailes et
qui montraient bien suivi donc j'ai eu
la chance de bénéficier de ces
formations et j'en bénéficie toujours et
on essaye de faire de même au district
aujourd'hui on serait je m'investis
aussi dans des districts des yvelines
dans la formation des jeunes
donc on essaye aussi de soutenir les
jeunes qui se lancent au tout à fait
est-ce que vous avez une situation
délicate en match à gérer alors oui ça
m'est arrivé d'avoir
on a tous eu des situations délicates
sur des terrains jamais eu de situation
très compliquée où j'ai été victime de
coups que ce soit comme on peut le voir
mais des insultes on en a entendu à tous
en tant qu'arbitre mais voilà faut
savoir faire obstruction faut c'est
aussi ça qui fait grandir mais très
délicatement
j'ai eu la chance de ne pas avoir de
conflit est exceptionnelle à gérer
est-ce que vous avez déjà arbitré des
joueurs avec qui vous avez joué ça se
passe comment du coup ça m'est arrivé
chez souvent des étangs ex joueur de
foot yvelinois j'ai pu côtoyer pas mal
de de connaissances sur les terrains moi
quand j'étais arbitres donc oui et même
en nationale 3 en nationale 2 ça
m'arrive de me d'arbitré ça m'est arrivé
d'arbitrer des amis même donc c'est pas
évident c'est je préfère arbitres et des
inclusions ne connaît pas évidemment
mais faut savoir voilà m l'amitié de
côté sur le terrain est vite rentré dans
la rencontre et on fait abstraction de
deux du côté amical qu'on peut avoir
on peut perdre certains amis peut-être
n'ont quand même pas un moment alors
qu'elle est la principale qualité pour
vous selon vous pour pour être arbitre
c'est une bonne question pour moi c'est
le courage faut être courageux pour être
arbitre est sportif évidemment m'être
courageux parce que voilà on prend des
décisions fortes faut savoir les vendre
et c'est pas évident donc c'est du
courage pour moi vous avez 25 ans est ce
que vous voulez aller encore plus haut
ces jeunes finalement pour pour
l'arbitrage
je suis assez jeune mais maintenant les
les jeunes arbitres commencent de plus
en plus tôt comme disait gabriel dans le
reportage qu'on a pu voir je suis j'ai
fonctionne un peu de la même façon je
préfère faire étape par étape match
après match saison après saison sans
voilà à mes fils et de me fixer des
objectifs à long terme met vraiment à
court terme et à moyen terme est tout à
fait ça se passe comment vous est à
noter c'est à la fin de chaque chaque
match chaque saison on est évaluée alors
on a plusieurs évaluations dans durant
la saison par un système de classement
et ça fait des classements du coup la
fin de saison et c'est un peu comme les
équipes les premiers montrent les
derniers descendent et c'est un petit
peu le même système que de notation que
les fins que les équipes pour tout à
fond est-ce que vous voir un jour
peut-être en ligue 1 c'est c'est
réalisable ou ça paraît utopique
prononceront plutôt puis quoi c'est un
rêve comme tous les arbitres de mon
niveau
on rêve tous d'évoluer à ce niveau là
mais voilà vraiment étape par étape et
et savoir rester les pieds sur terre et
être humble fait c'est important je
pense dans l'arbitrage mais heureusement
comme en question de façon permanente
quels sont vos modèles justement en
arbitrage alors moi quand j'ai commencé
on a tous pierluigi collina en tête
parce que voilà c'est un arbitre très
charismatique l'italien mais moi quand
j'ai commencé à arbitrer c'était howard
webb l'anglais une série de solides
italien que les deux qui ont dirigé les
finales de coupe du monde 2010 et 2014
et donc c'était des modèles et beaucoup
d'arbres en sait aussi que que je
regarde assez fréquemment évolue en
ligue 1 donc sur lesquels on essaie de
de prendre l'exemple de s'inspirer un
peu de chacun de différents différents
côtés donc c'est intéressant justement
s'inspire sur quelle phase de jeu plutôt
des phases j'imagine compliqué peut-être
à gérer pas forcément ça peut être des
phrases assez compliqué mais aussi très
simple les déplacements la gestion
disciplinaire la façon de communiquer
les postures les images c'est très
important et c'est des choses qu'on
essaye de des choses vont vraiment qu'on
essaie de s'inspirer de tout à fait mais
la question qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour la suite de votre
carrière dans gharbi tous déjà de
reprendre le championnat sur une saison
complète parce qu'on a eu en nationale 2
on n'a pas eu la chance d'aller au bout
du championnat on est encore dans la
tente de la reprise ou non des
compétitions mais mais voilà après pas
de limites d'aller le plus haut possible
et de se donner les moyens d'y arriver
surtout merci à vous félicien gazon
continuera évidemment vous suivre dans
léa prochaines années on espère vous
retrouver en ligue 1 peut-être un jour
pourquoi pas en ligue des champions et
on l'espère ça en tout cas merci
beaucoup alors on va terminer par du à
tennis et une montée en puissance il est
actuellement le deuxième français à la
rai arturo reina knecht est en pleine
progression
à 25 ans est é vie noir originaire de
saint jean les pointent désormais à la
127e place mondiale après avoir atteint
les quarts de finale à marseille battu
par le français ugo humbert après une
balle de match
le sportif d'un mètre 96 jours à cette
semaine le tournoi challenger de lille
une victoire lui permettrait de se
rapprocher du top 100 au mondial c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tb
[Musique]